hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's corrie Q&A everyone had tons
of questions about the giant mech what
team core is going to do what kind of
is going to go down the finale so
let's get to it also real quick heads up
if you guys would be interested in me
doing live q and A's on my twitch
channel just let me know I'm totally
into doing that I'll explain how that
might work at the end of this careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet but starting with
question number one snoogle man s by
only question is why a giant mech and
why only one why don't have a fleet of
ships blimps or even tanks you're
basically saying like have like a giant
army yeah I think the reason is is
because they wanted to do something
different visually from a visual
perspective Mike and Brian and kuvira
wanted to do something that would just
terrify people it mostly made me think
of Evangelion but a lot of people
pointed to Iron Giant there's a whole
lot of mecha anime that you could point
to Mike and Brian like to reference a
lot of their favorite anime like fooly
cooly so if there's a big anime series
out there that you really enjoy I'm sure
that there's something in legend of
korra that is a reference to that
usually it's really minor things though
but the other thing about the giant mech
is that you could point to the drill at
bossing say just a giant super weapon so
I think it's less about the giant itself
and more about the idea of the super
weapon there's a lot of the more
technical people I've seen commenting on
how the recoil from the laser would rip
the arm off the giant I try not to over
analyze that too much then there's the
issue of the reload time there's a lot
of big questions that haven't been
answered about it that I think that
they'll address in episode 12 when team
Korra tries to take it on so short
answer giant mech because they wanted
you to crap your pants and they've
already done sequences like that so it
wouldn't be as surprising and you
wouldn't be able to do that awesome
Godzilla reveal so see they just want to
go out on a cool ending damn the logic
question number two 3s isn't Korra
spirit bender can she bend the spirit
weapon think or something so it's
possible that she could absorb the
energy from that plast as far as we know
she could only redirect it or dodge it
whenever she was fighting you nevah to
she was acting more like a tank just
soaking the damage we haven't seen her
do a Yoda thing where she absorbs the
energy and dissipates it but I'm really
hoping is the solution to the laser is
going to be something much more personal
like they'll use bitar jr. to sabotage
it he
helped build it so he should know how to
take it down that just feels much more
personal to me him turning against the
person that he loves and I do think he
still loves kuvira even though she
totally just tried to take him out they
were a whole lot of questions about
what's going on inside kuvira's head so
I do have some theories question number
three Kristen asks what do you think is
going to become a bittar junior and
kooky relationship when everything's
said and done so I actually feel
something really tragic coming on I
don't think that Cooper was gonna die I
don't think Cora's gonna kill her if she
does die it's not going to be because
cork crushes her skull or anything it
seems like they both love each other and
he's just going to love her behind bars
I think the real question is is what
needs to happen before the characters
can forgive each other for what's
happened kuvira seems pretty
irredeemable at this point so either she
goes to jail or she dies either way I
don't think the bitar juniors gonna stop
loving her if you remember he suggested
that they go home so that they could be
together I think he's going to try and
find a way to sell her on running away
so they can be together off by
themselves wandering around there been a
lot of big characters like Ozai for
instance he just became a nomad and
walked around for the rest of his life
kuvira could do the same thing with
guitar junior at this point he does not
care about Republic City or the earth
Empire or anything he just cares about
kuvira kuvira is the one that's got her
head messed up that's one of the only
big complaints that I have about this
season so far is because it's so
condensed we don't have time to get the
side episodes that explain why kuvira is
so hardcore question number four team
bzees how long do you think the kuvira
has been building that giant mech suit
they couldn't have built it before they
discovered the spirit vine weapon uh
yeah actually I do I think they started
building it the minute they took xiaofu
I don't think the mech was built because
of the spirit vine weapon I think that
the mech was built to be a mech and that
they just attached the spirit vine
weapon to it after the fact question
number five purple conscience asks do
you think that will see Zuko again in
the battle maybe even azumi yeah a lot
of people asking about the Fire Nation
WTF is the Fire Nation yes I do think
that they'll show up at the end but I
don't think they're gonna get involved
in the conflict i think the conflict is
pretty much over there will still be a
battle like they sell to take down the
mech and they have to deal with kuvira's
army but it's not going to be the big
war that it was going to be before
President Raiko surrendered don't worry
they're not going to pull the rug right
out from under us and do an action
lyst finale they're still going to be a
lot of fighting but if you're asking
about Zuko fighting like he fought in
book 3 no I don't think that's gonna
happen I just think he'll show up at the
end if we'll get that final moment where
all the world leaders meet in Republic
City question number 6 davida suez what
do you think about Prince Wu he's been
doing oddly good lately yes I think they
just want to show that he can totally
lead the earth Kingdom like he has a
brain inside his head even though he's
kind of dumb he's something of a Varrick
character someone who has intelligence
but it's not plainly evident just from
talking to them like he knows how to
deal with people like he's a people
person he doesn't do really well with
technical details that's why I think
that when they deal with kuvira he's
going to be installed as the earth
Kingdom leader and he'll be a much
better King than the earth Queen was
much more democratic and yes I do think
that ma co will become one of his
advisors and everyone we be bummed to
seem team Korra split up but remember
the world is small they can travel
around pretty fast question number 7
avatar song asks do you think the batard
Varrick will turn the spirit cannon into
another spirit bomb so you're saying
like will they sabotage it and blow it
up I think yeah I think they'll take
down the mech and they'll take out the
weapon I know it seems confusing about
why bitar might help them but I think
that they'll be a deal like he'll have
something in his head where he thinks if
I help them take down this giant weapon
and disable it then they'll let me leave
with kuvira and we can be together as
for Varrick they said that a couple of
the hummingbirds survived so I think
they help pilot want to go and close
Julie is probably the one that would
pilot in that situation in varrock would
just go in and try to take out the
weapon platypus duck bear to the rescue
question number 8 Emil asked do you
think that will ever find out why Cuvier
so intent on uniting the earth Empire
will a cast member died in the last
episodes no I'm not expecting anyone to
die i don't think the core o Kabir is
gonna die i mean it is it is possible i
mean it's the final episode of Cora Cora
might sacrifice herself I hope that she
doesn't and I think I said it a couple
times but I don't think they're going to
completely explain why Cuvier is so
crazy about uniting the earth Empire I
think she just wants the land because
people want land it's like Israel it's
like you take a piece of land and say
this is for everyone now but it actually
belonged to another group of people
before that so becomes this big conflict
in real life just like it is with Israel
and Palestine I think the character
would have come off a little bit
if they had shown her as a liberator but
at this point I think they just want her
to be the clear villain I'm not feeling
super sympathetic about her so maybe
something is going to happen in the next
two episodes that will make her a little
bit more sympathetic like maybe
something happened to her and her
childhood that we don't know about yet
maybe something happened to her and her
travels I think it would be a big
disservice to not mention any of those
things but it's the kind of question I
think they would totally answer at
comic-con so if you do get a chance to
ask some questions at comic-con they can
totally illuminate stuff like that if
they don't do it on the commentary
that's actually another place to so look
forward to the DVD commentary question
number 9 sapphire star ass do I think
the kuvira would feel hatred for the
Fire Nation because of what happened
during the hundred year war go after
them because of that so I think Cuvier
would probably find any reason that she
could think of to take their land
regardless of where her head space was
like what she was thinking her logic
before I think now she's just gonna
invent whatever reason she needs to
accomplish her goal to rationalize it in
her head like killing bittar I think she
saw the quarter was going to use him
against her so she wanted to take that
advantage away it's not quite as clear
as it was with sahir it's not
institutionalized evil so here was a
fanatic about his ideas I mean he still
is he's creepy in that way he's so calm
he doesn't seem crazy at all he's just a
little intense we haven't really seen
kuvira's motivation so that's a bit of a
weakness of the series in general but
yeah I think she would just invent
whatever reason she needed to go off to
the other nations question number 10 re
an ass do you think the kuvira is going
to go all mental like Azula in the end
who that would be fun I don't think it's
gonna be exactly like that but I do
think that she's gonna break down I
think we all kind of expect Kourt to win
so that means career has to lose she
seems really cold but she doesn't seem
like she has things together quite as
much as the here did I think if anything
is gonna make her break down it would be
bittar jr. I think the two of them I
think it'll be something really personal
at least that's what I'm hoping I think
that would be the best way to go out
like you had a mon and tarlac you had
the two brothers together they went out
that way I would like to see something
similar with kuvira and bittar hopefully
they won't commit suicide I don't want
to see that if she is Hitler I don't
want to see her commit suicide like
Hitler did in real life Hitler and Eva
Braun I guess that makes bittar jr. Ava
Braun in that situation thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
always a ton of fun to do a lot of
people are asking me about doing last
airbender videos yes I will be doing
those allow me to explain so what's
going to happen is is next week we'll
get the two-part finale I'll do a couple
of extra videos for that just specific
to the finale and then I'll try and
start posting avatar last airbender
videos within a couple of days of that I
don't know how frequently that's going
to happen whenever TV comes back in the
spring I'm gonna have a much harder time
my video schedule is going to be a lot
more full so it'll be a little bit
harder so it might be one a week but we
can figure that as we go along also to
about the live twitch q and A's so I
always answer questions whenever I'm
streaming games on Twitch but I can
actually use that I can use the twitch
channel to just answer questions for
stuff it doesn't have to be for video
games so if you really want to see me do
live Q&A s4 stuff just let me know in
the comments below the twitch channel is
just twitch / emergency awesome there's
a link in the description I like twitch
a little bit better than I like Google+
just the technology is a little bit
better I only have a webcam for that
which you can actually see on the top of
my computer here it's not quite as good
as the camera that you're seeing me on
here but if people really like it and we
do it a bunch then I'll get a nicer
camera so it looks better from that
angle congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Lauren Bassam on
everybody give her a high five you win a
copy of the book 3 DVD just be sure to
message me on the back end of my channel
so i can get contact details thank you
in advance so do not forget bring an
extra pair of pants next week Legend of
Korra two episodes next friday the pride
just post them boasts on the website if
you're on your mobile phone or on a
tablet there's new extra links up here
you can click on is the same as the
links over here but click here for my
episode 11 video and click here for all
my other core videos thank you so much
for watching so let's all have I I will
see you guys tonight
you